let's bring you some breaking news now
out of ethiopia's tigray region a
ceasefire between government forces and
rebels has been agreed to
in the capital michele and we're getting
reports that forces from the tigray
people's liberation front are in control
of the city
after government forces withdrew several
hours ago ethiopia's military with the
help of eritrean troops
has been battling forces loyal to the
tplf for nearly eight months
and a conflict that has displaced two
million people
now this is a developing story we're
going to speak now to a resident in
mckelly
uh he works for doctors without borders
uh thank you for your time just tell us
what you're
seeing hearing there in mckelly
uh thank you so much for having me
if you can hear me sir can you just tell
us what you are seeing and hearing
uh about what's happening there on the
ground
uh yeah the like three hours or four
hours ago there has been
fireworks and a lot of people cheering
due to the fact that the kids have
already
in control of the city
and the similar people are uh
all over the city clearing you know and
a lot of fireworks are uh being held
that's what exactly is happening in the
field
all right thank you uh for that we're
gonna go now
to malcolm webb who's been monitoring
developments from nairobi he joins us
live
malcolm what are you hearing well what
we've heard speaking to people on the
ground there michelle is that within the
last couple of hours
the tigray and defence forces the tdf
have moved into the city we heard that
there was heavy fighting between them
and the government troops the ethiopian
national defense forces
around the airport initially around the
airport we've heard people on the ground
saying that the tdf
took control of the airport and taken
control of three
key road checkpoints that lead into the
city
we haven't been able to speak to them
ourselves and the government haven't
commented yet on this either but
media channels online media channels
which are closely affiliated with the
tdf's leadership
uh have reported since that the tdf's
taken control
uh the city of mckelly and as we just
heard them from the gentleman on the
phone
reports of people celebrating in the
streets tdf soldiers and local residents
and shooting fireworks there are
pictures on social media that seem to
show that we haven't been able to verify
them but people we've spoken to on the
ground
say that that's what's happening
meanwhile the head of the interim
government
of the tigray region that was appointed
by the central government
had requested the central government for
a ceasefire
and we've just seen a tweet a short
while ago uh from
an and a statement from the prime
minister's office saying that uh they
have indeed accepted uh that ceasefire
okay uh malcolm sorry if i'm being a
little bit too simple here but
you're talking about the tdf to gray and
defense forces is this forces
uh with the to gray people's liberation
front
it's a great people's liberation front
uh was the
uh well initially an armed group but
then they uh they're the group that
dominated ethiopia's politics and
military
uh for nearly 30 years uh until prime
minister abi ahmed
uh took power three uh years ago then in
december last year the ethiopian
national defense forces launched uh
an operation a military operation in the
tigray
uh region against uh the the tplf as it
was called at the time now since this
conflict has uh
has developed they've uh they've become
the tdf the tigray and defense forces
they say that they're representing
the tigran people uh the people of the
tigray region who they say
uh have been persecuted by not only uh
ethiopia's military but also the
military
from neighbouring eritrea in a conflict
that's uh that's
gone on ever since uh the ethiopian
military moved in in late november early
december
last year but these events that we seem
to be seeing right now this
uh takeover of the city of michelle is
certainly a change
in direction from the way that the
conflict has gone uh
over the last uh seven or so months
since it began
malcolm we've got about a minute uh left
just remind our viewers i mean this has
been a very
violent very bloody very difficult to
cover conflict with
uh cuts and communication trying to get
information out hasn't it
very difficult from very early on the
government cut off internet in
most of the towns and and the telephones
have been cut off as well
road travel is very difficult it's very
difficult for people to move around
the province is very difficult for
humanitarians
to get access we're able to piece
together bits of information from
uh reports and from people who've left
there made it to the capital addis or by
snippets of information we can
piece together on phone calls but access
to the press has generally been
very restricted and at the same time
they've been growing reports of massive
human rights abuses massacres of what
people now believe must be thousands
of civilians since that conflict began
all right thank you very much for that
malcolm webb